[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello hey my mic is on that's awesome
is the text here large enough do I need
a bump for anything I do things in HTML
so that you know you can do that [ __ ]
oh my clicker is not going though let's
get that fixed you know what I didn't do
I didn't plug in the dongle so with a
quick pause for dongles there we go hi
I'm Miriam Suzanne that is definitely a
picture of me and I'm glad to be here
thanks Jen in case you don't know me I
run a bird with my brother
we're a full-stack agency small team
doing client work for various people I
recently started learning JavaScript
sorry being introduced to JavaScript
it's the one language you cannot learn
everything else is learn about so mostly
I've done lots of HTML and CSS and then
dabbled wherever I need to so I've
mostly been known for Susie which I was
told to use as an introduction because
people might know it even if you don't
know me and then show like that it's got
lots of downloads but I don't want to do
that I want to tell you not to use it
because grids are so let's say six peas
right that's going back a little too far
but good so while you were all surfing
yesterday I was just on my way here
sorry I showed up late but I'm here now
the TSA took my toothpaste so you're
safe
but fortunately the hotel has given me
some more so you're safe but let's talk
about CSS and we're going to start with
a little bit of history thanks Jen
so in 1993 we got the first HTML spec
that's this is my company in 93 we were
just doing our first client planning I
think their card sort of some kind a
little bit later we got the font tag in
tables which was great we could start
styling these documents that we had
these HTML documents and in case nobody
screamed it out you recently yes tables
are for data a little bit later actually
earlier if you're looking at when the
spec was first released but later if
you're talking about when it was
implemented in browsers we finally got
CSS cascading style sheets and HTML and
CSS were both built around this
principle of least power what is the
least powerful language we can build
that will solve this problem we need and
that was a guiding principle of the
design of these languages which is
important to know when we're looking at
the history of them so we got CSS and
it's awesome thank you
that's my talk you've all seen this I
you should know I think that this is
absolutely a feature if you had a design
tool that could not handle overflow of a
box you would ditch that design tool
immediately you need to be able to
handle overflow this is a feature of CSS
and we CSS actually gives you various
ways you can handle it and that's good
the problem with this is just that a
designer didn't look at it also in 2000
same time that browsers were picking up
CSS we got the DAO of web design from
john Alsop how many of you have read
that article or know of it a few so
that's an early manifesto saying
limitation of the printed page is that
it's the same everywhere and we have to
stop thinking about that as an advantage
of the printed page that we should
achieve with CSS and instead think of
that as a limitation that we can now go
beyond we can start thinking dynamically
we can start thinking about how things
are gonna look for different people in
different places on different browsers
so this is actually the first time we're
talking about should everything look the
same in every browser and John Alsop
says no around 2007 to 2010 and this is
when I was starting my company we got
the major grid frameworks blueprint oo
CSS 960 at this time grids were starting
to become popular you had 12 columns
gutters between them you were able to
span the columns and this made sense to
me that grid systems would become hugely
popular at this point because we were
using floats and we were dealing with
lots of browser bugs with floats so
every time you made a float you had to
set it to display inline and then you
had to handle various bugs across
different browsers and it was a mess
so these CSS frameworks which were as
far as I recall the first open source
tools that we had as CSS developers
maybe Eric Meyers reset was in there
somewhere but these allowed us to skip
most of the hacks and ignore that part
of the process which was nice so those
became very big that's the same time
that I was actually starting my company
and I saw this talk not live because I
was not in London but thanks to the
Internet if you ever have a chance to
watch this talk it's still relevant
there's a few things in it that are out
of date since 2008 but Natalie down was
proposing a different way of working
with CSS moving away from those
frameworks that were a library of CSS
code and with plain CSS all that we have
is an API when we give you
CSS framework the only API available is
selectors so these were just lists of
selectors that you could use and some
people still use things like that today
she was proposing that instead of a
library full of selectors we could
instead have a system and use consistent
systems so that would be more like BEM
or oo CSS now OS ESS had its framework
but sort of these systems of thinking
about CSS systems of naming things
conventions that we can use across every
site to build consistent grids without
having to use the same grid for every
site that we work on so she was also
working with fluid grids she would put
fluid percent based grids inside of a M
based container and that way it was
responsive to both font size and window
size and this was before responsive
trademark became a thing and really the
the basic difference with responsive was
that it involved media queries I used
her system quite a bit but the math was
really ugly I simplified it here target
divided by context times 100% that's how
you do fluid math but figuring out what
context and target is once you include
gutters can be very complex and at that
point we didn't have sass so actually I
think it existed but nobody knew about
it so my CSS looked like this I was
typing that into a calculator and then
copying and pasting it and nobody had
any idea what my CSS meant there's no
way to know what that's for
soon after that compass and sass did
become more popular and finally our CSS
is turing-complete
it sort of breaks that principle of
least power but I looked at that and
said ok great I can start writing out my
math that's meaningful
not perfect so that's where Susie came
in
I wrote Susie just to take that math and
make it readable that was the entire
point it only does that one equation
good done but what we're going for is
code that's readable both to humans and
to machines that's what we want from the
start we want code that can be read by
other developers as well as read by our
browsers so that it's rendered and
that's the goal and SAS helps with that
we're naming things we get to take this
HSL which some people aren't gonna
understand necessarily what exactly
color that is and we give it a name and
we say not only what color is this but
we can say what do we use it for why is
it here
we can give it a purpose so as Sarah
Dresner says code is communication and I
always have to mention she only said
that once and she complains every time I
quote her on it so sorry Sarah in 2009
we get media queries and then in 2011 we
get calc and calc is really interesting
and it has been around for quite a while
and well-supported more than its used
kal gives us the first ability to mix
units in our CSS finally we can add a
pixel to a percentage and get a result
because calc is calculated by the
browser the browser has access to the
Dom it can figure out both of these
numbers and then add them together so
that's something that SAS will never be
able to do because SAS will never have
access to the browser given all of those
pieces Ethan Marcotte writes his article
gives a talk announces responsive web
design basically saying we need to
target all these things and this is a
fraction of what we're looking at and
it's not just devices we're trying to go
beyond targeting one man with yellow
hair and beyond this and beyond this and
you know we don't even know
things about these people just from
their pictures but we're trying to
target lots of people in lots of places
so we need to remember that though CSS
has a declarative syntax CSS is in no
way static CSS is built for from the
start it is built to give us ability to
make change and to style change how does
this look different in one place versus
another place and those are the sorts of
rules that were writing in CSS it's not
here's how it is forever but here's how
it should handle different situations
that's what CSS is written for so part
of that is going with the flow you may
know the concept of the flow these
things are in an inline flow and they
move in relationship to each other
we can toggle that to a block flow and
see that they move in a different axis
but the flow is useful because it sets
up relationships between objects rather
than having each object on its own on
the page if you've got if each object
was on its own when I change the size of
one I would have to hard-code this size
change for every other object in the
flow but the flow gives us ability to
just let those relationships move so
responsive design said we're going to
use fluid grids flexible images and
media queries to manage how the flow
changes at different sized screens on
different devices that was a new idea
putting all that together it's
interesting media queries were available
much earlier but nobody was really
paying attention to them until Ethan
wrote that article in 2014 and I was
surprised by how long ago this was we
got CSS variables Firefox 31
unless you count current color current
color has been a variable that we've had
since the beginning it stores the
current color in your CSS and that's
figured out by where you are in the Dom
not just where you are in the CSS file
but a variable we didn't have
access to changing at that point now we
have access to change these and tab
Atkins wrote the spec for this it looks
like this you can define the color and
you can then call it so it's basically
an empty browser prefix on a property
and the goal there he says was that he
was actually trying to slip in a new
feature called custom properties nobody
would go for it he called it variables
and they bought it
so he's now working on the next step of
that which is to make it more powerful
as a custom property this is how you
access it you use the VAR function in
CSS now you can call the property name
and then you can also give it a fallback
so that's useful if the property may or
may not be defined in some ways that's
similar to variables in sass we've all
worked with variables before I hear
JavaScript also has variables though I
can't guarantee it
so sass variables were rad when we got
those we were able to clean up a lot of
our code they hold beta they're useful
for that they store something they make
it reusable they help us make our code
more dry that's great but sass variables
use scope the way we understand it in
most languages where we look at the file
and we can see the scope because columns
two is defined inside of example and
even though nested class is nested in
the Dom we don't know that it's nested
in our code so it has no access to
columns two and when we change something
at a media query we can change the value
of columns there but it only changes for
that scope so it again isn't changing
for everything in the media query or
everything that uses it it has no access
to the Dom it's just scoped in the file
like we would with in other programming
languages that's the big difference here
with CSS variables we finally have a way
of
scoping to the Dom the same way that CSS
does that cascade that we're used to or
maybe not used to so what that means is
that when we set columns to in example
all of the children nodes in the Dom of
example will have that value even if
they are not nested in the style sheet
and that means that we can now change a
value at a media query and have that
trickle down to everything at that size
in the browser so that's a very
different way that these work and really
changes how we think about them and how
we use them in order for them the by
default they inherit everywhere if we
put them in the root tag then I really
mean everywhere everywhere that makes
this color available throughout our
entire document so that's something that
we can do if we really don't want things
to inherit we can set them to reset to
their initial value on every property so
this is a useful way to say certain
things should not inherit let's reset
them every time if you need that one of
the things that I most love about them
and have started using them for right
away is that they make inline Styles
totally safe there's always been a
problem with inline Styles being too
specific it's impossible to override an
inline style if you need to but when
you're just defining a variable inline
you don't need to override it you can
just ignore it so it's totally safe to
set any variables you want to in your
HTML which is a great way to pass data
between JavaScript and CSS you can set
the variable in the HTML it's totally
safe CSS can ignore it when it needs to
has access to it when it wants and
you're still separating those concerns
while communicating between them yeah I
already showed you how to use them so I
don't know what this slide is for so
I'll just give you a moment with it
while I have a drink
think on that you know what about that
fallback color it's a bit bright right
so you can call it there or you can
ignore it so that was the point of those
than I just should have gone through my
slides faster another thing that you can
do that I've used it for a lot is if I
don't want excessive nesting in my CSS
if I don't want really specific long
selector strings I can avoid it by
changing a variable at the at the root
string where I want it to change
and then just grabbing that variable in
the button so I can suddenly make
buttons look different in different
places without adding any specificity to
my button selector I like that that's a
really nice way to avoid increasing
specificity when you don't want to
another way to use it you can start to
create defaults where they're missing
and missing longhand so box-shadow for
example only has the shorthand property
if you wanted to change any one part of
a box-shadow you would have to redefine
the entire box-shadow
but with variables we can set each
property as a variable and then we have
access to change that variable
individually that's also really useful
for things like transition transform
that have different properties you want
to transform and then a last way and
this is less and less needed this auto
prefixing but you can create mix-ins in
a way if you have multiple properties
that need the same value we can use them
that way
like we would use mix-ins in SAS but
where I start to get excited is when we
start combining them with calculations
so now I can pass data in to CSS and
manipulate it and return a new value so
as a test the first thing I did was I
rebuilt Susy entirely in CSS
there's no sass involved here and it
works in in fact the background images
are also generated by CSS variables calc
and a background gradient and you can
see the full demo there if you go to the
link and this is how it works
I'm just setting the same global
settings that Suzy has the columns the
gutter the spread the container spread
and then I have 50 of these functions or
so the interesting thing about using CSS
variables as functions is that they can
only hold one value at a time so you can
only have one calculation per element
which is not particularly useful but it
works so then in use using it this is
all of the code for defining the final
layout
I just set how many columns there are
and then say how many I want to span and
I can change how many columns are
available for nested context and all of
that works very smoothly so and then the
background images also uses that and
calculates out the background it don't
use it really like this is overkill it's
totally not worthwhile but that concept
is useful if you do want a grid system
in your HTML passing in columns and
gutters and then defining how they're
used in the CSS that's a that's a good
way to go the reason you shouldn't use
mine is because I tried to solve all
layout problems at once and you don't
need to solve all they are problems at
once you have your one layout problem
another thing that I just started
playing with and this is there's a
article on CSS tricks that inspired some
of this is manipulating individual
values of the HSL function as variables
and then
getting to change them individually for
example creating a darken and a
compliment
and being able to use those where I want
so I can start to create a theme based
on CSS variables so the fun thing that
they were showing in the article is the
way you can use clamped values so this
would be to say the the color wheel
no the lightness scale from 0 to 100
will clamp at 0 and 100 so if you go
under 0 it will stay at 0 if you go over
100 it will stay at 100 so you can use
that to toggle back and forth between a
black and a white by multiplying with a
negative value or with a positive value
you can do something similar with the
color wheel if you go over 360 you're
still on the wheel so you can simply add
to get the complement so here's a little
tool that I built that just lets me
adjust so the threshold is where we're
doing the toggle what lightness do we
want to switch our main color at and
then as we change color when we go past
the threshold we change so this is a
rudimentary way of doing color ratio
accessibility it fails a little bit
because you'll notice that if we have a
blue and a yellow say there are
different times when they ought to
switch so it's not perfect because we
don't actually see color
purely by lightness so again probably
not useful right away but the concept is
fun to play with we can now start
creating themes purely in our CSS
passing in one color and generating the
other colors that we need through
JavaScript I here this is a JavaScript
conference so I threw in this slide you
can access and change the custom
properties like you would access and
change any other property in CSS there's
a lot more come
sorry that's all that I know I've only
been introduced and actually I should
jump to this one first there's a lot
more coming in terms of JavaScript mean
manipulation of CSS variables right now
it's all behind a flag in Chrome but you
can start playing with it it's called
Houdini because it helps you escape from
the confines of CSS something so there's
a few issues when you start playing a
few gotchas types aren't defined
currently and that's part of what
Houdini is gonna help us solve so when I
put in a string or a color CSS doesn't
yet know the browser doesn't yet know
what it is so it has trouble animating
it so at this point you have to animate
the property that it's put on not the
CSS variable itself because the browser
doesn't know how to animate an unknown
type they don't work inside of the URL
function which is too bad I've had
problems with that several times and
then another thing you'll notice the VAR
size M I can't
concatenate things like that so I have
to use instead calc var size times 1/m
the browser can do that math adding an M
unit that way but it can't do string
concatenation so that's unfortunate
hopefully we'll get that eventually part
of what we're gonna get from Houdini is
this ability to register properties and
define their syntax define their type
and that will start to allow the browser
to do some of these things that we can't
yet do so if I were tab I would show you
a demo of that but I'm not you can learn
a lot more from leav rule on this she's
done some amazing talks that just dive
into variables and everything you can do
with them and if you've never seen her
talk her talks are amazing she live
codes the whole thing and I can't
so I'm gonna start to put that together
with CSS grid instead of going more into
depth with that CSS grid was fun because
it suddenly landed in three browsers all
at once
in March of 2017 it was one day not
usable and the next day I woke up and
could use grid and production which was
fun we were in the future now or more
relatable we're in the future now that
boat is awesome whoever built that there
is seriously nothing like it it so.when
CSS grid landed I stopped getting
invited to conferences because I was
known for Suzy and Suzy was dead that
day like that was dead CSS grid is
totally unique it can do way more than
any sass a library that there is if any
sass library claims or or what's that
other one post CSS if any of them claim
that they can do what CSS grid does
they're lying to you don't believe them
it's really unique because all of the
calculations are run by the browser it
has access to the Dom it can do mixed
units in a way that nothing else can the
spec is very complex and I've seen lots
of talks on grid go into detail on the
spec and people are scared away getting
started doesn't have to be reading the
whole spec there's a lot of ways to get
started very quickly it basically looks
like this the grid is defined on the
container so you can say display grid
it's just a display property you can
define columns and rows I only showed
columns there but our normal historic
twelve column grid we can create with
that line of code repeat twelve one
fraction and then we can put in gutters
without having to do any math of our own
optionally so that was defining it on
the container optionally we can pass
control of sizing on the grid back to
our elements using the auto keyword
and so what Auto does is it just returns
to the flow
what would this element do naturally on
its own and we looked at the flow
earlier on the inline axis and on the
block axis if it's confusing
there are several different units in CSS
now that all have to do with percentages
of the space this is your cheat sheet
for them so a percent is relative to the
parent with actually that's available
space in the parent so that wouldn't
include padding the VW unit is relative
to the entire viewpoint viewport so 100
VW is the entire width of the window and
fraction is the new one added in CSS
grid and what it means is how to share
remaining space so a fraction unit takes
up a percentage of remaining space
that's similar if you've used flex box
to the Flex grow in Flex shrink which
have no units it's exactly the same
context how fast should this shrink or
grow to give up or take up remaining
space one tricky thing about the
fraction unit if you define something as
one fraction it automatically assumes
you mean min max Auto one fraction so it
will only grow and not shrink because
auto is the minimum and then it's
allowed to grow to one fraction so if
you actually want something to shrink
and grow you have to set a new minimum
so I have quite a few of these in my
code min max zero one fraction to allow
something to shrink completely grids
wants you to find a grid you get a
layout like this you have your grid
lines and they're one indexed and then
they're also negative one indexed so you
can access them from the front or from
the back and you have this sort of
single source of truth that you can
create this is starting to build out
more complex defining different parts of
how we're going to relate to this grid
but we can basically draw this
ASCII art of our layout and then say the
header takes up both columns and is
sized Auto for its vertical and then nav
is on one side main and is on the other
side and then the footer goes across
again and then we define the column
widths at the bottom and then for the
layout similar to the Suzy demonstration
we just pass in the name and it
automatically goes there and actually
this ignores the order of the elements
in the Dom so no matter what order these
are in the Dom we can pass them to the
right area of the grid so there's a lot
of power there be careful with mixing up
code order Dom order and visual order
but there's good reasons for it
sometimes so right away with those
couple lines of code we have a full
standard layout and that's it and really
CSS developers are all going to get
fired because this is gonna be just too
easy so Jen Simmons who's been doing
lots of the work on the grid spec and on
informing people about it
has sorted call this intrinsic web
design the next step after responsive so
instead of just being fluid it's both
fluid and fixed we can mix the two now
they can live together we dealing with
stages of squishiness so something can
be fixed or it can use fractions to take
up remaining space to be somewhat fluid
we can use min max to let something be
fluid until it is fixed and we can use
auto to return to the flow so we've got
all these different stages of how we're
handling squishiness in our elements we
finally have truly two-dimensional
layouts we get columns and rows which is
totally new in CSS revolutionary to
dimensions and we can start to mix these
things there's no reason that
floats are gone forever I've already
heard some people talking about floats
like we talked about tables for a little
where a teacher was refusing to allow
their students to float anything that's
absurd floats are still useful for what
they were invented for which is floating
images in text they have a narrower use
case they're not gone but we can start
to mix these things so when we want
things to align and flow in one
dimension flexbox is better for that
when we want to go into two dimensions
grid works great sometimes I go back and
forth on those between whether I'm want
to define the spacing from the child or
from the parent so there's different
reasons to use them and we can start to
nest those and get different outcomes we
can expand and contract our content in
new ways we can change justification
very simply we can change how things
wrap for the flow we can start to flex
things using the fraction unit etc and
then media queries are only needed
sometimes because we get things like
autofit and autofit that figure out for
us how many columns we have space for
and then it just fills them in which can
be really useful for something like
image gallery
or masonry like layout but I want to put
all these things together and we started
playing with this right away on a client
project last year being able to pass in
values from JavaScript just pure data
gets passed in we're building a
scheduling app we want to know when an
event starts and how long it is so we
passed that in as CSS variables and
using calc and grid we manipulate that
data and we can say we have this many
minutes in a day let's create a column
on the grid for every minute of the day
and then we're just passing in a start
and an end and we use those as grid
lines to tell every session on this
schedule where to start an end so we got
a layout in about 10 minutes using just
some CSS variables and some grid and it
builds our schedule for us which I love
the limitation here is I don't remember
the exact number
there's only we were able to do 16 hours
and then you hit the limit of how many
columns a grid can have so if you need a
24 hour you're gonna have to step back a
level and do two minutes per column but
you can get to 16 hours worth of grid
then I've played with this with bar
charts this is just the HTML for a bar
chart you could also use tables for this
I decided on definition lists but just
some simple semantic markup and I pass
in the value of 45 value 100 and I can
even change the scale up top in my chart
and then this is the math I take each
chart starts at the scale plus 1 because
to handle the indexing minus the value
of where we're wanting to start and
again I played then with how it adjusts
color based on the value that's passed
in and using just those variables I have
this completely fluid grid and I'm
actually going to inspect it here so
that I can let's see where's this scale
let's change that to 200 there we go and
everything adjusts so I don't know why
you need to change the scale on your
chart but you can and I love this idea
of being able to manipulate raw data in
CSS so that JavaScript only has to pass
us what is known and then the Styles can
decide how actually to use that data to
generate something next I want to play
with see if I can do line graphs and
plot charts I think plot charts will be
easy in line graphs will be much more
difficult but have fun with that start
playing with those things here's another
one that I did somebody presented some
generated art they had done so I redid
it in view and I can start adding
invaders or removing invaders and I can
click on them to change them and I can
shuffle them and then I can kick ass and
like drive around shooting them yes yeah
give them so that's important if you
want to dig more into grids grid by
example comm is a great place to go this
is Rachel Andrew site it has not only
lessons on the different aspects of grid
but also common layouts built in grid
with fallbacks already built so if you
have one of the common layout needs or
something similar to it you can copy and
paste her code
and already have your layout written
also Jenn Simmons has youtube.com slash
layout land where she does various
YouTube videos going into much more
detail she also has Jenn Simmons labs
where you can see lots of experiments
her doing various art sites playing with
what grid can do so this is I just want
to remind you CSS is in fact awesome
thank you
you